Theo Vaughn just had a coroner on his
podcast but that's not even in the top
three most random guests he's had on the
show because two years ago this past
weekend featured a female trucker who
taught the Rat King all about lot
lizards but there was even more piping
discussed during episode 249 when
theophon had a plumber on the show one
of the coolest Parts about Theo is that
you don't have to be famous to get on
his podcast just ask his little nephews
whose interview back in 2021 received
2.6 million views now let's talk about
some of you guys's plans for the future
I know you guys right now are you're
nine years old you said zephy and Mac
you I can start the full list of Theo's
interviews with random people includes a
mortician a border patrol agent a turkey
farmer a retired police officer and a
doctor